i'm here with our exercise guru ben
eater hi sal and we're looking at your
exploring standard deviation 1 exercise
and let me think about what's going on
here so it says arrange the 13 orange
sample points in the histogram below so
these are the orange points you're
talking about so the sample standard
deviation is approximately 1.6 so just
so i understand these these are points
that are being sampled from some
distribution right we get these points
right over here and then
this your your module is automatically
calculating the sample mean right which
is kind of the the central tendency of
of at least these points it's estimating
the mean of this population you're
sampling from and then also the sample
standard deviation right which is really
kind of a measure of how on average a
way to measure on average how far away
they are from that sen that that sen
that sample mean yeah and what we're
trying to do here is to kind of get a
sense of what that actually means right
we say this the standard deviation is
1.9 what does that what does that sort
of feel like right so it seems clear
that the sample mean it looks like you
know it literally is the average of
these numbers right it is and it is it
looks like it's you know if i move this
out then it moves to the right a little
bit but that's just one point the mean
moves to the right the mean i think
it's easier to have an intuition for the
mean yeah because there's a lot of
people it's more
to the right here then the mean moves to
the right if we have move stuff move to
the left and the mean moves to the left
that makes sense but the the the
standard deviation in this case we're
measuring the sample standard deviation
right this is a this is a measure of
dispersion right
and i say on average in quotes because
it's not exactly the on average that we
typically well and that's and that's
kind of the point of this exercise is
it's not kind of exactly you know on
average so what is it right right but
you see that the further so let's see if
the further the points are spread out
the wider this sample standard deviation
is if i bring the points closer together
then the standard deviation gets smaller
and smaller if i bring them closer to
the sample mean right as you see they
get they get tighter and tighter right
so let's see let's do the actual
exercise so arrange the 13 orange sample
points so that the sample standard
deviation is approximately 1.6 so right
now it's 2.1 so i want to squeeze things
together and there's no right answer
here i just have to get them in in a way
that i'm close to 1.6 so i want to move
things closer to that the the sample
mean
and so
let's see this one so one point by
itself actually just moving this one
point
so
that just one that one point didn't
quite do the trick but i could move more
things in yeah and i it really could be
like i could just pick out another point
move it closer to the
lots of ways to do it i'll have a bigger
impact if i move something that's right
now far away and move that closer in
that's right because right now that's
kind of taking that okay as that looks
right yep 1.6 so let me check my answer
correct now look at this
excuse me look at this show solution
okay let me look at the solution
the standard deviation is smaller if the
points are closer to the mean yeah the
standard deviation is larger the points
are more spread out try moving a point
closer to and further away from the
sample mean to see how the sample
standard deviation that's telling us
what we just did right
look at the next look at the next step
oh there's another step and what this
will do is actually show you different
examples of how to get to 1.6 so if you
click that it'll show you maybe a
different way
oh that's neat and i'll click it again
right and so what you can see is there's
lots of different ways to have
a sample standard deviation of 1.6
and they may look different but if you
keep clicking that you'll kind of see
there are some things in common as far
as how they're sort of grouped close to
them and one other thing i just want to
clarify is you know you've drawn this
this kind of this bell curve with that
area shaded in in the back
that is
that is our estimate of what the real
distribution might look like based on
the information we have of the sample
right so
if if if our sample mean is accurate if
it really is estimating the true mean of
this population then that's what we're
drawing in the middle
and then we're assuming it's a normal
this kind of bell curve shape
distribution so that's what it would
look like based on the information we
have right this is very cool